[Musique]
il a réussi à combattre les mygales les
serpents la peur la faim et des
conditions extrêmes pourtant m6 l'a fait
craquer le célèbre aventurier mike horn
a décidé de quitter la chaîne sur
laquelle il officiait depuis 2015 pour
rejoindre rmc on pouvait clore avant ça
et c'est là où j'ai pris un choix exit
donc à l'état sauvage ou cap horn
elissonde aventure culte de la chaîne
mike se lance désormais sur rmc
découverte où il va commenter les images
d'archivés de ses expéditions les plus
folles à -70 tu peux même pas faire pipi
lors tout s'est tu vois même pas ton
petit machin en 2019 mike horn avait mis
sa vie en danger lors d'une expédition
au pôle nord dont il garde un souvenir
douloureux
cette fois ci l'idée de continuer à
faire rêver sans se mettre en danger on
veut faire découvrir des endroits peu
connu encourager la préservation de la
nature
tout le monde peut réaliser ses rêves à
programme à découvrir dans les
prochaines semaines alors mike horn
quitte m6 pour rejoindre rennes ces
bonnes idées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que c'est une mauvaise idée
parce que je regrette comme si ce n'est
pas donné les moyens pour faire ce qu'il
voulait sur la chaîne je trouve qu'il a
été sous exploité sous la chaîne sur la
chaîne m6 et je pense que du coup il
part mais à contrecoeur alors
effectivement rmc découverte c'est très
bien pour lui mais m6 aurait dû lui
donner les moyens et c'est sur m6 qu'il
aurait monté sans moyens je pense que
c'est guère de choix des mariannes c'est
regrettable
rachel absolument c'est dans l'adn de
l'homme et de l'émission je pense rmc
donc c'est vraiment un excellent choix
et je crois que vous avez participé moi
à quoi vous devrez vous n'aimerez pas
faire cette émission d'aventuré
moi j'étais une ford gt fois donc en or
ils vivent est quand même très froid
christopher oui son émission devrait
arriver à la rentrée du mois de
septembre / sur la chaîne saab et mike
horn suivre survivre à l'impossible ça
va être fait des images d'archivés de 30
ans de ses aventures les plus extrêmes
rappelé qu'elle dure au diane's alors on
a failli perdre la vie mais c'est pas du
quai pas non plus d'autres boulangers
journée parce que c'est vrai qu'avec m6
m6 et plus laden du divertissement
finalement lui celle aventure c'est plus
laden aujourd'hui il atteint donc les
chaînes qui commence à avoir de vraies
de aussi il y aurait donc seulement la
série documentaire il y aura une dizaine
à peu près plus un programme inédit
là ça va arriver tout doucement mais
quelle prise pour rmc découverte est en
train de se forger une identité
ils ont aussi recruté aller mais antoine
de maximy avec j'irai dormir chez vous
c'est bien la chaîne de l'aventuré et ce
serait diffusée dans le samedi samedi
aventure donc mais le
contre-programmation face aux fictions
du service public et au divertissement
parenthèses les questions d d'audience
de m6 découverte sa défense en quatre
cent mille en moyenne mais là oui c'est
pas le 457 me lâcher on est un peu mais
di mezzo parce que c'est vrai que pour
rnc découverte c'est une superbe prise
parce que c'est y rentrer dans les cases
parfaite du dépassement de soi de
l'aventuré tu sais mais je pense qu'il
va un peu en pâtir parce qu'il aura la
même exposition que sur l'asie parce que
les gens naturellement vont plus
facilement sur un disque aussi loin dans
la tnt avec hélène ces découvertes sont
sales et voulait plutôt bien mais oui
parce que ça développe parce que rmc
découverte et ils ont leurs spectateurs
et franchement ils attendent que salon
de trouver mike horn sur cette chaîne je
pense que c'est une très
toujours sur ce tour il avait récupéré
faites entrer l'accusé le public a
largement suivi
je pense surtout que mike horn c'est
quand même un aventurier il la passion
pas de problème d'ego et de s'exposer
mais j'ai beau jeu par l'illusion la
même opposition dont l'âge varie
aujourd'hui son but c'est surtout lui de
de s'éclater de faire une émission qu'il
est élu à l'instar de la télé c'est pas
un animateur avant tout c'est comme les
sportifs